well this will be the last question
we'll just have everybody answer greg
i love this question gregory alba asks
which video game would you most want to
live in
for a day if anyone has an answer
otherwise i'll start
calling like a teacher what am i doing
taika what video game would you like to
learn ask me first don't ask me first
okay jody what game would you like
i've already said i already said this
i'm gonna say it again and it's
embarrassing and there's a tumbleweed
every time i say it but i want to go
i want to be in harry potter i want to
be in harry potter guys that's where
you'll find me
yeah exactly every time but i'm sticking
with it
joe how about you i i'm trying to think
like what would be like kind of
the least dangerous you know i don't
want to you know i don't want to get
like my head chopped up yeah i could do
the same thing this is pretty dangerous
depending
on that might be the point might take
out the water yeah
maybe some game where i get to fly so i
guess i'll choose a state like star fox
i get to
you know fly this kind of cool
spacecraft that seems pretty cool
bro this is gonna sound
insanely random but it was a video game
called
charles barkley shut up and jam
and every time you lost the ball he'll
say go get the damn ball so we used to
like get my brothers
you should just lose the ball of prayer
i mean my mom walking in like oh you're
cursing like no it's the game
like who bought this guy he's like go
get the go get the damn ball go
so it would have been fun to be in that
video game and just play charles barkley
and have him tell me to go get the damn
ball
at the age of 10.
[Laughter]
kirsch i mean i would piggyback on that
like
for you guys about wish fulfillment and
my first dream was to be
the first indian in the nba so if i
could
i was really hoping for it this is all
plan b guys
i would jump into nba 2k you can get a
player that looks exactly like yourself
that would be 6 7 6 8 2 16
points
maybe the my home team washington
wizards win three to four championships
in a row
something small like that um something
achievable
um so yeah i think nba 2k would be my my
go-to
damn ryan oh boy i mean i loved mike
tyson's punch-out as a kid
i you know like a little bit like rally
we used to quote like
you know back back in the fight back in
the fight every time i
have three older brothers so we were
constantly there was just constant
messy stabbing deaths all over my house
all the time so there was
we're always sort of at war but if i had
to really pick i know this is kind of
unexpected or maybe it's expected i
would actually kind of like to be in
free city i know it's not a real
video game but the the the video game
that we've created
where this film is set i like the colors
and the vibes in there or something
i know it's dangerous as hell place to
live but like
i think i would probably take that and
it's and it's interesting to me because
everybody sort of
says oh it's a you know this movie based
on a video game or a video game movie
i really don't think free guy is a video
game movie it's sort of like
saying you know titanic is a movie about
boatsmanship
uh it's not i mean it's a it's it's a
movie about so much more
but i loved the narrow target we had to
hit to create a world that
felt so authentic to gamers uh
and then still sort of smuggle this
other this other story into that was a
a pretty pretty special kind of thing
yeah
taika coming back around to you uh yeah
okay what
i never had uh i didn't have any money
for a video game in my house guys
so uh oh wow so you know i grew up when
you had to
walk into town with 60 cents and
you get three goes at a video game in an
arcade
so but there's a game i was particularly
good at called defender
and uh i would probably be a pilot and
defender it's a
super stressful game um i like it quite
well
uh but people who i mean for
modern context uh i like to play a game
on uh do you know you guys know roblox
yeah with roblox if you've got kids well
i go on roblox with my daughters and we
like
go on and we play wolves and we just
wonder
you should do it you just like turn into
a wolf and then you make your kids be
wolves and you just
walk around the landscape looking at
waterfalls and stuff
very peaceful well thank you guys so
much we're gonna have to wrap it up but
sean just
on an ending note what are you most
excited for audiences to see
when they go see free guy oh boy
this cast come to life in a movie
that feels in some ways like an antidote
to much of what we've been living
through
in that the movie is about hopefulness
and the preservation of some innocence
in the midst of a very cynical world and
championing
that hopefulness and that optimism so
i'm excited to finally share it with the
world
well thank you all so much thank you to
everyone who tuned in free guy
is in theaters august 13th all right
thanks everybody thank you thanks guys
thank you
cheers guys bye cheers